c'est Emmanuel Macron il est en visite
en Australie
[Musique]
est-ce que vous australiens présidents
d'Australien il le reçoit monsieur
Macron va faire un peu la visite de
Sydney on va se balader en Australie et
là ils sont en voiture et un mouton qui
passe et Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que
c'est que cet animal il dit oh ça c'est
un mouton regarde chez nous en France
les moutons qu'est-ce qu'ils sont gros
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont balaise c'est pas
mouton ça il marche et tout et d'un coup
il lui dit et ça c'est quoi il dit ça ça
c'est un lapin
déjà les lapins en France ils sont
balaise grand super et là d'un coup il y
a un kangourou qui passe yo ça c'était
quoi petit dessin c'est une sauterelle
[Applaudissements]